hi i'm bimarunmi i'm emma daly yakima
and this ramadan i'm going to be making
some nigerian style potato and egg for
sahur and i'm going to be making some
pakistani style pakoras for iftar
ramadan is a month of the islamic
calendar and during that month you fast
from sun up to sundown every day and so
sahora is the pre-dawn meal you have
this before the sun comes up and when i
was growing up the thing that we had
most commonly was something that we
nigerians call egg singular always egg
you can put anything in there like
sardines or corned beef or sausages or
whatever like it really is a diy
situation i think like eggs are like a
really common thing they're easy to
quickly high protein super nutritious
and they fill you up for longer so you
don't feel the pangs of hunger nearly as
much you're looking at basically like 12
to 19 hours of not eating or drinking
during the day and that includes water
before you ask fasting means different
things to different people but it's
ultimately a way to try to make yourself
a better person during the month of
ramadan unfortunately also what happens
is sometimes when you break your fast
you're very hungry and you eat a lot of
food so the thing that i make is
something that i like shovel in my face
when it's time to break fast tell us a
little bit about what you're going to
make for iftar so iftar is the time
where you break your fast you know you
hear the call to prayer you eat a date
and you drink some water and then
somebody's probably already preparing
the food and one of the things that we
always prepare is this bakora which is a
fried vegetable fritter the pakoras can
basically be any fried vegetable it's
like the chickpea flour is the thing
that really makes it what it is usually
potatoes onions jalapenos eggplant it's
really anything you want so it's like a
really
special treat this is like the unhealthy
side of your fast breaking um what i
love about pakoras is that um they're
not always pretty they're just like a
whole bunch of massive vegetables and
batter on top of them so i like it when
there's like a lot like a jalapeno and
an onion and a potato in one pakora they
are like a really special thing of
bringing people together where everyone
wants to pluck them right out of the oil
when they're hot they don't even get
into a plate really you know because
they're best when they're immediately
crispy out of the oil
[Music]
i love ramadan every year it makes me
feel really connected like there are
literally millions of us across the
world all doing the same thing at the
same time i find that really
heartwarming and it makes me incredibly
happy like i'm really part of a global
community
yes
[Music]